welcome American Idol artist KC and
former artist from The Voice Meaghan
McNeill blending my two worlds I loved
it I was so excited to have you both on
but each of you is doing something
unique so Megan we'll start with you
you were on the voice like right before
I started Yeah right yep I was nice to
you season 13 yeah that's a number two
amber yeah so I think that was the
season that Chloe cohan ski 1 and I'm
from Chicago and so I landed on Jennifer
Hudson's team which is like alright we
have a video actually I'm Megan singing
on chicago's l chain recently went viral
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
as a mom who is rocks at BabyBjorn like
I never looked that cool like you have
your baby rise up while you're like
hitting those notes that's some big
notes on a train especially you know we
I was like I got all the thing that I've
been doing you know this video of us on
the train just kind of like chilling
hanging out is the one that's gotten all
this attention but I'm like it is the
most authentic like expression of myself
because I'm like I'm not taking the
stroller on the train so what happened
is a friend of mine Avery Young called
me to be a part of this series the
floating arts museum and Avery is like
there's always performers on the
platforms in Chicago but we want to like
push the boundaries take it a step
further and like bring this musical
experience to people on the train car
and I'm like Oh sign me up I love it he
said so we're gonna do this series
called soul L we're gonna bring the
performance right on the train and I
said well I'm free that day Avery but
I'm not getting a sitter so I'm bringing
my little baby with me and instead of
like putting in the stroller on the
train I just wrapped him in this Moby
Wrap and I say he looks so cool I'm like
I would have tried to do the same thing
and it would have not been there but
Mason I sung with him up until about
eight and a half months being pregnant
with him so he's used to like all of the
music and everything there at the end
like your diaphragm just changes like
the end of pregnancy Oh am I not you
okay oh oh yeah me neither
I've nailed everything No and in my
pregnancy I would that people wanted me
to record something I was like like I
could hit breast though it's horrible it
was pretty awful I know what's the goal
behind these performances so the
floating arts museum wants to connect
people through arts culture and music
just to do different programming to push
those boundaries and to bring people
together which I was so grateful for
because that's the only thing I ever
want to use my voice for is to
regardless of class race gender you know
disagree it brings everybody because
this is
so for that to happen in that space was
just you know a dream and it doesn't get
more Chicago than like deep house music
on the train in yeah I think that's cool
I think that's gonna become like a
tourist attraction wait have you done
this cuz I'd go you were on season 13
right with Jennifer Lopez she's a judge
yes yeah
and I do have to say she's shockingly
beautiful in person it's annoying almost
hard to look at almost hard to look at
I'm like what I had to do this thing
with her and I was like you're closer
switch and I was like we obviously we're
the same size as Holly thanks for
pointing it out jack never enough do
have a time no but you have it's your
you matter kind of campaign right you do
the concert yeah I'm at a concert you
know I went on Idol and it was amazing
it's it's it's a huge opportunity for
artists you get this national platform
and as I've been growing the standard
artists route I've also been doing this
other concert that I run in schools and
it's called the you matter tour and I
have all these songs that I wrote as a
kid that were about growing up about
being 13 15 and 17 and I just wrote them
because I was sad sitting on my bed at
15 years old yeah cuz Tina is your dog
really rough and I now I go to schools
and I'm like yep it is as bad as I
remember it but you know I'm I'm able to
take those songs that I wrote and I go
to schools now and I use them as a
jumping-off point to talk to kids about
what they're going through it's really
cool it's hot junior and high school
those were those were rough awkward
years but I love that it's also you you
connect with people about bullying -
yeah you know so I had my own
experiences with bullying I think most
everybody does and I wrote this song and
I played it in like a classroom and I'm
very loud so kids kind of formed outside
of the classroom oh that's and I went to
put my guitar away and this kid who
always picked on me and anyone who's
been chronically bullied knows that when
that person would walk up to you like
the wall goes up here like oh oh no what
she's already yeah he was that you yeah
he was like that was awesome he walked
away oh wow and I realized that the same
personality
said I was being punished for having
like in life are the ones that are
celebrated on stage and so when you go
on your slow
honest with your words and your lyrics I
found that it's always connected me with
people and that is holding true in this
anti-bullying program that's really yeah
I was I was bullied fooling in this
whole time yeah I was bullied in like
the fourth grade my dad was like is he
smaller than you and I'm like I was a
small kid this guy and and I'm like yeah
he's a lot bigger than me and he's like
then just punch him right in the nose
and run away
so I went the southern dad yeah
Midwestern dad don't hunt they're very
similar and so I did the next day at
school he came up to me and I was like I
can't and knocked him right in the nose
and ran off and then my aunt's now works
with the guy and last Thanksgiving she
came up to me aunt patty she came up to
me and was like hey Adam can I talk to
you for a second
and called me like into another room
she's like I didn't know you were a
bully in elementary school and I'm like
what I'm not a bully and she goes do you
remember Brian and I'm like Brian was my
bully Oh taking my bully in and twisting
it all around on him your childhood from
you yeah he's taking my bully right we
have a message from a student in Boston
there that Casey connected with take a
look hi Kelly I'm Samantha Madigan I'm
so thankful to have been given this
opportunity to thank you because for all
that she's done
she made me feel like even though I was
different never naps at high school I
wasn't alone just because I like
performing arts and everyone at my
school pays for it she showed me that
there are others like me he's a true
inspiration her message showed me that
if you love something keep going no
matter what anyone else says I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this